you guys ready for this one sure let's
go we got this tweet from Jack pesobic
did someone film a Chinese girl and AI
felter her white to make this video
that's trending all over Tick Tock I
want to play this video for you guys you
may have seen it and maybe I shouldn't
zoom in like that we can we can get you
more video let me play this video for
you
well we don't need any of the sound it's
just a song so for those are just
listening you have this young white girl
looking at a wedding ring and every
every time she puts her finger through
it she gets a vision of her being a
housewife and being miserable and she
hates it and then she takes the ring off
and she scurries away
so there it is again she puts her finger
and then she's washing dishes then she
puts her finger in and then she's
folding laundry now
Jack besobic is saying did they put it
on a Chinese girl why well first if you
look at if you if you pause in some of
the uh Clips you can see let me see here
here on this shirt the writing appears
to be Chinese there's a couple different
instances where the writing appears to
be Chinese and in fact behind her it
looks like there are Chinese people and
the reason why the The Conspiracy Theory
here I believe most people are uh saying
I don't know about an AI filter you need
to do that you can just get a white
person who lives in China but the
argument is they are trying to attack
Family Values they're they're trying to
attack marriage and the family in the
west and this is on tick tock tick tock
is not in China they have their own
version of tick tock this is another
component of if your kids are on Tick
Tock they're being indoctrinated with
content that tells them to hate being in
a family not wanting to be a mother and
this is exactly it but this content
appears to have originated in China
right and this just goes against what
you're saying before about how World War
III would be fought if you're dealing
with China you're dealing with the
United States you're dealing with a
country that's trying to undermine our
own values while also obviously being
made perhaps light years ahead of us in
terms of the technology that they have
so um you know this is just another
um front on the on the the information
Warfare that we're seeing between China
and the United States and undermining
our own values undermining uh what it
means to be a woman obviously yeah
um and attacking the family attacking
the family really getting to the core of
it how miserable they make her look like
she hates she's cleaning things she
hates having kids right I I think it's
sad that they're taking this moment like
she's getting an engagement ring right
that's supposed to be exciting you're
with someone you love and instead it's
like if you take this you're basically
getting handcuffed to a life that you'll
hate and that's that's just so cruel to
take something that's that's actually
supposed to be nice I think part of it
too is making it seem like
they're not showing you the other side
of this like she wants to be what alone
and still cleaning her house like some
of these things you do anyways you would
rather do them what miserably I don't
really understand what their counter
argument is I mean I'm interested in
knowing whether this is actually a real
actor or AI I mean I don't think it's AI
you don't think it very well could be I
mean AI is getting crazy it is
pretty face change I don't think it's
even a phase change it's like the hair I
mean you literally just look she she may
be Eastern European let's let's talk
about how this Refugee from from war
comes they say hey come to China we'll
take care of you or quite literally
they're white people who live in China
they could just be like hey you wanna do
this the crazy thing about this is you
need to consider this is a heavy
production how many let's see let's see
how many costumes there one two
let's see
three
that's we saw the one four
Four costumes so far looking at the ring
decent I mean not super high budget but
uh she's got five
who made it and it looks like who made
this again funny Vlog 89 6 costumes and
a and a pregnant belly and so it looks
like six costumes in total uh uh on on
what appears to be probably six
different sets
this propaganda is
I think this is a component of fifth
generational Warfare The Conspiracy
Theory I suppose is that China is trying
to attack our uh rip us apart from the
inside because there is a real concern
that we're going to war at some point
and they want us off off base falling
over Etc publicly since we're weak I
mean we're not rejecting strength right
now on the international stage with
Biden so um yeah it's it's right up
their alley it's it's I mean you would
expect them to do something like this
you'd expect them to do more of this
given how weak we are currently as a
country
um but you know because even if it's not
AI even if this isn't you know a Chinese
production it's still incredibly sad
that our culture is now villainizing
marriage on their own right like we
maybe it started maybe some of the
influence of like anti-family uh
propaganda came from somewhere else but
if it was just a regular girl who made
this on her own like that's still not a
great sign I know it goes to show the
scope of the psyapping and how many
people are buying into this she takes
the wedding ring off and it's like nope
and it's like damn like I'm I'm the last
guy like I'm not in any way like a
conservative when it comes like or a
Puritan kind of person like those really
cool guys I'm as not it has nothing to
do with being cool it has to do with
like not talking smack and then people
being like well yeah but what about when
you were a drunk 10 years ago
that's more it is I'm covering my butt
um but like you know your Society is
based on like all societies are based on
families first it's okay to have like a
different lifestyle and not not want to
have a a traditional lifestyle but your
Society absolutely should promote
traditional Lifestyles there's nothing
wrong with with being like yo men and
women should get married and have kids
because that's how we continue our
society and as much as there's a lot of
people out there that that are are
screaming about
um about the the over overpopulation
about and worries about climate change
and stuff if I understand correctly the
the fact that so many societies are
getting so old now like China and the us
is going to be a pretty old society and
you're having that happen throughout
Europe the birth rates are are so low
that we don't have to worry about
population or overpopulation there's
going to be a population collapse coming
I've been listening to a lot of videos
and there are people that are talking
about by the end of the century the
world global population could be cut in
half well and that means that fewer
people that are getting fed properly
that means fewer people that are working
on like Innovations and working on on
you know things that'll help progress
society and make Society make life
better for people so the the idea that
we have to limit how many people we have
being born or that we shouldn't support
uh or we shouldn't uh encourage families
and stuff that's that's ridiculous and
it's anti-human in my opinion well and I
think part of what she's objecting to
right that like when you get married you
may have to take care of your house or
you may have children that have needs
like I don't think it's actually wrong
to acknowledge that some of those
aspects of Life are probably hard and
you're lonely if you're a young mom at
times like there are things that we can
acknowledge being a sacrifice that are
still worth it and you're you're saying
you know we have aging populations but
they aren't reproducing children so
she's saying oh I don't want to get
married and take care of a house and
kids like she's definitely not going to
want to take care of her aging parents
right like we are breeding a culture
that says uh my needs and my wants in
the moment are more important than
anything else and the idea that I may
have to at times do things I don't want
to is completely repugnant to me all
right and that's why birth rates are at
all-time lows across the West I mean in
the United States we're obviously having
to replace our native born population
with people from the third world through
crossing the Mexican border so you know
the bottom line is you know you know
you're not going to have a society that
can't reproduce I can't replace itself
they they try really hard with this uh
idea of social was it social
constructionism constructivism Phil you
know is it constructivism or social
social construction yeah so like the
idea that that you human beings make up
most of the things that we do yeah
and so what they do is they try to push
on guys
stop being like a guy and on girls start
being like a guy and this results in
less families so when they it's funny
when they talk about the population
collapse that's coming there was this uh
viral story which was really interesting
there was a a defense contractor put
together this document that said in a
few years there would be something like
30 of the global population would be
reduced or some ridiculous number
and then they deleted it and got rid of
it and everyone's like why did they why
did they publish that what is that all
about some people thought it was talking
about war it may just be that not
necessarily in the next couple of years
but the next couple of generations are
gonna have dramatically less people I
mean people like the birth rates are
dropping rapidly over time
what I think we end up seeing
is in response to this you can create
social pressures that stop people from
getting married finding girlfriends
finding boyfriends having kids but the
desires within people don't change you
end up with women who are severely
depressed probably because what do women
want there's probably internal feelings
to them that are family oriented like
just men have the same thing but they're
they're told basically to suppress that
like these videos like don't get married
don't have the family she's she's got a
baby and she's looking miserable like
having a kid is bad but people are
rejecting this what we're end up seeing
now is we got 12th grade uh boys I guess
once you get 12 you're about to be a man
and they're becoming overwhelmingly
conservative you get the rise of
personalities like Andrew Tate obviously
promoting masculinity Jordan Peterson
because no matter what they try to do to
suppress it you can't rip that out of a
human being seems like an indoctrination
video I mean we should be promoting
having a family that should be the flex
yes absolutely and being and being
feminine and and this is promoting being
masculine and you know
someone should make an inverse video of
this where it's like a depressed looking
woman and she like goes for a beer and
then when she drinks it it shows her
just like absolutely miserable at home
with like some cats and then she puts it
she puts it down and then she looks over
and there's a ring and she puts her
finger on it shows like her smiling with
a kid and they're laughing and they're
popping champagne and all that good
family stuff there was a reason why like
Mommy vloggers lifestyle vloggers of
like young Mormon women who typically
get married you know much younger than
the average American were so popular
they LED that industry for a long time
it's because that's actually what's
aspirational to a lot of women right
they want family they want to feel like
they are beloved and that they are
beautiful and that they have an
important role in life that espec
predominantly for most women is at home
and I don't think that's bad I think
that's why you have to have videos like
this that are like well when you're
married you have to clean and that's bad
like I would hope more and more people
are beginning to wake up and see these
videos and see it as absurd for what it
is and you know see it more as parody
than something that they're actually
subscribing to and believing I know
there was a recent study that came out
this past week showing that more and
more young people especially people
under the age of 18 men are identifying
as conservative than ever before
although at the other on the other side
of the spectrum more women are
self-identified as liberal so but I
think that'll change I think I think the
women are going to be propaganda as
having quite an effect though on women
young women and and it's because I think
women are more uh susceptible to social
pressures than absolutely but that also
means that if men are more object
oriented and women are more subject
oriented men wanting goals and missions
still of course wanting girlfriends
if these young women want to get
relationships it's going to have to be
them going to the guys and then
accepting the guys as they are which is
conservative values and that's why I
think we see women become more
conservative when they get married some
say there's no Coral it's not it's
correlation it's not causation and that
conservative women are more likely to
get married that's why you see married
women are conservative but I actually
think we've gone over this before there
is data showing that when women
pre-marriage they're expressing liberal
things then they get married then later
on they're expressing more conservative
things probably because their life
changed they made some realizations
they've experienced things I think that
also will end itself to these young
liberal women they're not going to want
to be single they're going to want to
have relationships and these young guys
are focused on their mission and their
goals they're watching their meme videos
they're watching their Andrew Tate
Jordan Peterson they're looking at Trump
and so these young women are gonna have
to be like well I can go and insult them
and tell him no but he's gonna be back I
got no time for this I'm busy or they're
going to have to come around to the
guy's point of view as they seem to do
traditionally right I mean from a
political perspective the society is
basically a compilation of a bunch of
families so you know if you can't
preserve the family if you can't build
up the family your Society is going to
collapse within a generation which is
what we're seeing so um you know from a
policy standpoint this should concern
you know if our lawmakers if our ruling
class was truly concerned about the
future of the country obviously this
would be a first order of political
issue that they'd be trying to resolve
obviously we're far beyond that point
but uh
um you know at some point we're going to
have to fix the problem otherwise we're
no longer going to have the country
which basically on the precipice right
now I think that's a reality and I think
a component of what's causing the inner
conflict in the U.S may be our foreign
enemies it's it's been a meme it's been
they said Trump was working for the
Russians that's nonsense but there's
discussion about Russia and China sowing
discontent on our social media thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time